je vous le disais en titre bd boum c'est
parti jusqu'à demain soir le festival
accueille jusqu'à 20000 visiteurs venant
à la rencontre de plus de 200 auteurs on
retrouve marine randonnée en direct de
la halle aux grains bonsoir marine par
le coloriage en avant la bd c'est plus
simple pour moi alors bd boum c'est plus
qu'un festival en effet il a une visée
aussi pédagogique
hier c'était la journée des scolaires
3000 enfants 130 classes des enfants qui
sont venus ici pour apprivoiser pour
s'essayer à la bd flavien texier et
grégoire gré choix ont assisté à un
atelier avec une école de cour cheverny
une salle de classe transformée en
atelier de dessin ces écoliers
apprennent à reproduire une bande
dessinée en quatre vignettes là on était
surtout sur un petit format donc un
découpage en quatre cases
donc le but c'était de leur faire
comprendre du coup le sens de lecture
déjà comment placer les bus les allées
placement des personnages aussi qui est
très important et apprendre à gérer son
espace l'espace de travail d'une case
moi je pars du principe que pourra être
capable de raconter une histoire faut
commencer par quelque chose de court et
simple c'est comme une blague on fait
qu'on racontera quelques heures qu'est
ce que tu as appris ce matin à bien
faire les dessins des bd aussi à parler
dans les bulles
pour pour bien dessinée si important
c'est ça qui est pas facile en fait sur
une planche de bande dessinée c'est de
raconter quelque chose on une seule case
le support utilisé un extrait de la
bande dessinée les petits diables
est-ce que tu as décidé le garçon qui
tente une autre table voici williams en
matière de bande dessinée cet écolier
maîtrise déjà son sujet et ses élèves de
cm1 ont de la chance leur enseignante
apprécié la bd et le festival va lui
donner l'occasion d'approfondir un
projet festival c'est le point de départ
qui me permet de travailler sur le
vocabulaire de la bande dessinée sur
comment on s'organise dans une bande
dessinée quelle écriture on utilise quel
est le vocabulaire approprié
et puis à partir de ça et on va
construire ensemble quelque chose avec
les enfants des teasers l'imagination
des enfants
une bd verra donc le jour avec pour
cadre le château de cheverny
tout un programme et je reçois
maintenant alain goût gris c'est un
enseignant missionné par l'éducation
nationale pour l'association bd boum
bonsoir alors dites-moi la pédagogie
c'est vraiment l'adn de l'association bd
boum qui a créé ce festival
en effet on peut dire que c'est l'adn du
festif estival et c'est dans les gènes
de l'association cette association est
née en 84 à l'initiative de
d'enseignants de deux travailleurs
sociaux donc c'est vrai que tout
naturellement dès sa création le volet
pédagogique a pris le dessus et et voilà
et donc on travaille tous les ans avec
énormément de classe qui viennent au
festival alors c'est pendant le festival
mais c'est aussi toute l'année un que
vous travaillez avec des classes
alors pour le festival 130 classes à peu
près 3000 élèves remet le reste de
l'année on a encore une centaine de
classes qui viennent de décembre jusqu'à
juin pour travailler la bande dessinée
alors avec un projet un peu
complémentaire avec des projets plus
long plus qu'aux plus prudents mais
c'est complémentaire de ce qu'on fait
ici au festival parce que pourquoi cet
important travail et sur la bd avec les
enfants ça ne rapporte quoi alors c'est
un énorme support pour la lecture un
support pour pour la culture pour la
médiation culturelle voilà donc on
travaille c'est vrai que c'est un médium
qui permet de travailler les arts
l'écriture la lecture
le dessin la peinture donc c'est un
associable source de réflexion et de et
d'inspiration pour les élèves
sinon parents s'inquiètent si nos
enfants dans que db2 or les mains c'est
pas grave ah non j'ai pas du tout grave
c'est vraiment une très bonne porte
d'entrée pour la lecture est pour les
chrétiens ont l'ouïe souvent l'appareil
d'écriture dans un scénario de bande
dessinée on écrit énormément
donc c'est très important pour les
enfants bien je vous remercie
merci d'un lingot grille et nous alors
vous voyez bd boum c'est une ouverture
sur le monde pour la bd alors notamment
pour les écoles s'ils veulent l'emmener
à l'école mais aussi pour les lieux de
privation de liberté alors bd vous me
travaille beaucoup avec les maisons
d'arrêt notamment celle de blois jeudi
il y avait une rencontre entre un auteur
franco argentin et les détenus à
regarder plutôt ce reportage
c'est un des cinq été publié sous le
titre faisant l'amour et pas la guerre
donald trump est le leader de la corée
du nord réunis dans un même lit c'est
l'un des dessins réalisés par michael
pour un titre de presse
il présente ce jour-là son métier devant
un parterre de détenus de la maison
d'arrêt de blois
ses sources d'inspiration le monde
contemporain l'émigration l'amour la
violence des thèmes universels
comme ici les dérives du port d'armes
aux états unis je pouffe l'absurde du
port des armes jusqu'à l'extrême ce dr
sam berceau d'un petit on peut imaginer
un bébé américain qui se nourrit déjà
des armes sur sur sa tête
les personnes présentes à l'atelier se
prête volontiers au jeu des devinettes
le dessin d'humour ça prend auprès de
tous les publics il ça me touche parce
que c'est une manière de de toucher le
public d'une manière différente
justement c c'est dérisoire et c'est sa
libre service de la pensée donc chacun
libre de faire ce qu'ils ont envie et
penser ce qu'il veut de ses dessins et
c'est ça qui est bien c'est ouvert au
monde quoi s'est ouvert aux gens sitôt
quitté la maison d'arrêt michael va
devoir plancher sur un dessin pour le
journal le monde je vous parle je
réfléchis à autre chose je me mets une
fois que je rentre à paris dans mon
appartement ou ici ça sera dans la
chambre de mon hôtel je planche
dans la feuille dans la page blanche
après une initiation express au dessin
les détenus vont repartir avec leurs
portraits sous le bras signé par l'un
des grands dessinateurs d'humour du
moment alors parmi les 200 auteurs qui
vont venir ce week-end aurélien
ducoudray qui vit dans l'indre et chef
pourquier dessinateur parisiens viennent
dédicacer leur troisième population
c'est une bd originale qui raconte le
quotidien des malades de la clinique
psychiatrique de la chesnaie mélanie
trash l'air et delphine la ronde
ils sont allés pour nous comment
distinguer les soignants dé soigner dans
un établissement aussi atypique
installé au coeur de la forêt de sologne
vingt ans après ce reportage le
scénariste aurélien ducoudray et son
compère jeff pourquier déambulent aussi
pour faire une bande dessinée un voyage
initiatique en immersion totale sur deux
ans on pensait être de petite souris
comme ça que voilà observer on peut
faire des croquis puis finalement l'état
impliqués tout de suite pour la montée
cet atelier bd et le retour étaient
formidables parce qu'en fait du coup ils
sont mis aussi à l'heure de la bd il ya
la bd partout j'avais fait des
affichages euros pour le boîtier qui à
la scène commune
c'était génial conférence santé et il
était heureux comme nous cette rencontre
des expériences fortes des lieux chargés
d'histoire tout ça transparaît dans ses
111 pages en 1956 quand claude jean
girard créé la chesnaie on parlait alors
d'humaniser la folie c'est beaucoup plus
dur aujourd'hui le moment de la
rédaction du scénario le le salon juste
était d'arriver à oppresser tous acquis
sans que ça soit indigeste
du coup il ya un peu compris mais les
journées compris même prix que les
autres y compris mais un petit l'outil
donc je sais pas ce qui était
intéressant c'est que jeff était là tout
le temps donc moi j'ai pas eu
l'impression de faire un scénario dans
mon coin je veux dire on l'a fait aux
faisans
[Musique]
ça s'est fait vraiment aussi en
discutant beaucoup et coralliens parce
qu'au départ inchangé à des choses plus
plasticienne plus plus avec de
l'aquarelle d encre et finalement lui il
a donné un ton un peu plus léger encore
plus humoristique en eau finalement j'ai
adopté un travail qui ressemble plus à
des croquis réaliste expressionniste ces
deux artistes présenteront la troisième
population à bd boum ce week-end et
c'est rené pétillon le père de jack
palmer qui a dessiné cette année vous
voyez la fiche de la 35e édition il
devait présider ce festival mais
malheureusement il est décédé le 30
septembre dernier alors les
organisateurs ont voulu lui rendre
hommage avec une exposition sinum
surnommé le prince de la bd nous l'avons
vu ce matin avec patrick gaubert que
nous verrons ensuite en invité avec nous
je commence à regarder dit ouais tu mets
ça toi tu es sûr que tu mets ça oui je
mets ça on va t'en va pas mettre ça
c'est un truc c'est vieux patrick
gaubert a passé des semaines à préparer
cette rétrospective avec rené pétillon
chez lui dans sa maison c'était quelques
mois avant sa disparition
aujourd'hui ce travail de recherche et
de négociation avec le dessinateur
permet au public de découvrir l'étendue
de ses talents
l'exposition montre toute son évolution
en tant que vd justement avant le canard
et c'est passionnant et c'est
passionnant parce qu'on voit des
planches très très différente à chaque
fois des références multiples un dessin
qui évolue et serments c'est vraiment
passionnant comme on à bernard pivot et
on a aidé rne alliés qui prend
évidemment déjà beaucoup de place de son
premier succès les disparus d'
apostrophes avec jack palmer son célèbre
détective créé en 1974 à ces dessins
satiriques hebdomadaire dans le canard
enchaîné les visiteurs retrouvent ce
qu'ils aiment tant chez le gentleman de
la bd pour le trait est très efficace
cesser
c'est j'aime beaucoup l'impertinence
tout en étant poli et comment dire pas
hargneux on sent des convictions
derrière qui sont durables et parpaings
versatile ça j'aime bien cette
exposition est une immersion dans
l'esprit de ce dessinateur malicieux et
autodidacte qui partageait son temps
entre le dessin de presse et la bande
dessinée son credo être sérieux sans
jamais traumatisé
alors on se retrouve avec monsieur omer
qui a commenté cette exposition et
carhaix le commissaire de cette
exposition bonsoir oui bon chemin alors
dites moi vous surnomme ici monsieur
dico de la bd parce que vous avez écrit
plusieurs dictionnaires de la bande
dessinée et quelle place à rené pétillon
dans cette histoire de la bd dans
dictionnaire de la belgique bat une des
places majeures tout simplement parce
que rené pétillon c'est bien sûr un
auteur de bande dessinée mais également
un auteur d'un dessinateur de presse
donc s'il fallait le catégoriser
peut-être pas mais en tout cas le m
quelque part ça serait entre entre ces
deux qui étaient voilà ces deux à la
fois le dessin de presse et la bande
dessinée et aux côtés de deux personnes
que me réserve comme wolinski comme cabu
qui furent ses proches et ses regretté
copains et voilà disons que c'est une
des places majeures de ces quarante
dernières années
pour vous qu'est-ce qu'il va laisser aux
jeunes générations
mais il va laisser une oeuvre
humoristique absolument immense c'était
surtout un auteur extrêmement
bienveillant bienveillant notamment pour
les jeunes générations
quand on en parlait avec des auteurs
comme blutch catherine meurisse doit
riad sattouf qui a évidemment le vent en
poupe à l'heure actuelle avec l'arabe du
futur c'était quelqu'un vraiment qu'ils
étaient à l'écouté et qui entretenait
les meilleurs rapports et rapports les
plus complices donc là pétillon nous
manque véritablement mais c'était un
grand grand monsieur et on salue
véritablement très fort dit c'est un
grand monsieur on dit que c'est le
gentleman de la bd expliquez-nous
comment il était
c'était tout à fait un gentleman c'était
quelqu'un qui avait son caractère on va
dire un fort caractère
moi il me disait qu'il avait de toute
façon toute sa vie durant fait ce qu'il
voulait et ce qu'il voulait c'est à dire
que on le voit à travers l'exposition
présentée à blois
c'est à dire qu'entre ses premiers
dessins des années 70 jusqu'à jusqu'à
ses derniers travaux
son dernier dessin en l'occurrence celle
affiche du festival
ça a été une perpétuelle évolution c'est
à dire qu'on est parti de dessinateurs
un côté un petit peu parodique à la mad
magazine jusqu'à l'heure actuelle et ses
dessins très proche de la presse merci
monsieur vous remercie pour ce
témoignage
on vous laisse rejoindre le jury parce
que là en ce moment il ya la remise des
prix 1
et puis demain va le festival continue
avec notamment un spectacle pour enfants
à 11 heures à la librairie à la
bibliothèque abbé-grégoire banon voulait
c'est plus on va aller faire un petit
tour sur maps arrêts merci beaucoup
marine tout de suite